boeing's popular 787 dreamliner is
facing a new manufacturing defect
which might sound familiar this is
another blow
for boeing the defect could take three
weeks to address which means airlines
won't be receiving dreamliners in time
for much
of the busy summer travel season recent
issues with the plane makers wide-body
aircraft
stretch back to last summer since then
the defects have prompted regulatory
review
a halting of deliveries a pileup of more
than 100 planes and are now pressuring
boeing's bottom line
this is not a situation boeing wants to
be in at this point
right now it can't deliver its most
popular wide-body aircraft it's almost
as if a company like apple couldn't
deliver
laptops so what are the issues with the
dreamliner
and how did boeing get here first a bit
of background
the 787 dreamliner made its commercial
debut in 2011.
promised all sorts of possibilities for
new routes
new efficiencies for airlines a better
passenger experience
and then it wound up on the ground in
early 2013 a fire broke out aboard an
empty dreamliner in boston
sparked by battery problems that later
surfaced on another dreamliner in japan
in two weeks time we saw two cases
of battery failures on the 787
and the grounding of the entire fleet
by the faa so the dreamliner had to
emerge
from that experience and regain the
confidence
of airlines and the traveling public the
787 is now one of boeing's
most popular aircraft more than 60
airlines including american and united
have added 787s to their fleet the
dreamliner is unique
as it was boeing's first plane designed
largely by other companies
its primary structure is made mostly
from composite materials for efficiency
because the dreamliners structure is new
in the world of aircraft manufacturing
boeing and the faa
are learning how its composite materials
and where those materials join
age over time so fast forward nearly a
decade of flights later to august of
last year when boeing voluntarily
grounded eight dreamliners
found with two different production
defects in the same location
for an aircraft manufacturer to do that
on its own is
something that you really don't see that
often the defects were outlined in an
august 31st
internal federal aviation administration
memo which was reviewed
and then reported on by the wall street
journal we first reported
about the dreamliner issues in september
when
the faa launched a high-level review
of boeing's dreamliner manufacturing
processes
at that time boeing and the faa were
trying to get their heads around the
problem
and they focused on one general area of
the aircraft
specifically the faa memo says they were
looking at non-conforming sections of
the rear fuselage or body of the plane
that fell short of its own engineering
standards the first defect had to do
with how boeing used shims or the
material that fills the gaps between
sections of the fuselage the second
stemmed from variations in the
smoothness of the fuselage skin
while the two types of defects
independent of each other
didn't pose an immediate safety risk
together in the same
section were deemed to potentially
introduce a risk
of a structural integrity problem in
extreme circumstances then the following
day
boeing flagged a third issue this one
with sections of the dreamliner's tail
that were clamped together
improperly during assembly it's not a
question of
immediate structural integrity it's a
question of whether or not they
introduce
premature aging and if so what does that
mean
for the dreamliners in service and how
often
they need to be serviced and fixed in a
recent internal video boeing explained
how thin these gaps are
if you start at the tail of the airplane
just walking to the front
each of those sections when we bring
them together is within
five thousandths of an inch you'll hear
people talk of gaps
it's really not what you would normally
think of as a gap
the next month in october boeing halted
delivery of the dreamliners
halting deliveries is a big deal in
effect that means boeing can't sell the
products
customers largely pay boeing on delivery
prior to the halt many of boeing's
commercial deliveries were dreamliners
as the 737 max remained grounded
following two fatal crashes of that
aircraft
boeing was at that point a month away
from
getting the is okay to again
fly passengers on 737 max and suddenly
it couldn't get
its other popular aircraft the
dreamliner
off the lot either then with delivery
still halted the plane maker expanded
its inspections of the dreamliner in
december
after it found instances of the
smoothness issue on new sections of the
plane
at that point it became clear that
the problem wasn't going away as quickly
as we might have thought earlier in
mid-march the faa took back boeing's
authority to inspect and sign off on
several dreamliners awaiting delivery
saying it would conduct the checks
instead it had echoes
of what happened after the 737 max
crashes
this action by the faa was a sign
of its increasing scrutiny
when it came to overseeing the
manufacturing process of the dreamliner
but later that month boeing resumed
dreamliner deliveries
taking what looked like the first step
toward moving past these issues
in april the company's ceo david calhoun
told investors the 787 delivery pause
was an example of the company trying to
solve its manufacturing issues
we've taken actions over this really
hard actions over the course this course
of this year
to stop things when we see an issue and
get them fixed once and for all
then in late may deliveries were halted
again as the faa requested more
information from boeing about its
proposed solution for catching and
addressing the defects before handing
over the planes to customers
boeing was hoping that it could get faa
approval
for the methodology to inspect using a
mix of physical inspections
and analysis with those discussions
ongoing boeing found the latest defect
around early july
this time on part of the aircraft known
as the forward pressure bulkhead at the
front of the plane
so it's going to complicate the process
that was underway of
going trying to prove to the faa that
its methodology
was sound it's still unclear when the
latest issue will be resolved though
boeing said it could take at least three
weeks to address
what we're doing on the 787 is a
methodical program
reviewing the airplane from tip to tail
in a way that's safe
and compliant for our customers and our
regulators
meanwhile finnish dreamliners are piling
up more than 100 planes await delivery
boeing has slowed production on the
plane and said it now expects to deliver
less than half of its 787
inventory this year the slowdown is
likely to ripple into
boeing's vast supply network and
for some weeks and months it's going to
mean that
boeing's airline customers have to wait
longer to get their new
dreamliners it's unclear whether these
manufacturing issues will matter in the
long run
whether or not there's any long-term
impact
good or bad to boeing's reputation
remains to be seen for now the
dreamliner is still a very popular
aircraft and has an excellent safety
record
[Music]